What saw it is First Story Oh the media
The fake News Next Sand in saddles
definitions with NBC for Confidential
Son Another sladdit liberal News outlet
has Thing of Justice Calling to use
Busters in a friday evening tweet From
The Fame The Man him self former coming
to  High School student Nicolas Sam and
angst that head Saddle his definition
Suit with and BC News were on disclosed
amount of Money What A fan Fair Sandman
poster The tweak reading that This Time
Out like to released that NBC and I have
riched a Sentiment The Terms are
Confidential zijn men studentbc for
overtoon 150 Million dollars I don't
know I do not Thank you got anywhere new
that but I sergenly Thing Is Gonna Be
Pretty comfortable Now I bring this up
and Next of this Story many was No the
history of Next Sandman  and the coming
to Kids but I wanna I wanna wrath The
spack into Kind of the currentuation
Around What happened on this show Never
Thing in Just say you know when I have
Come forsage W  ith someone and There UPS
Dennis but There World view is based on
media lights You Need To Look at the
next time in case You Need To Look at
the Justice League
and you can start The understand Why
These People are trap than is broken
World makes no  Sense or even The Iraq
War other banker bellout I less Show
me things that the Corporate media We
Know spread Lies About That We Are
Completely Absolutely Natural So This Is
The Sandman cases Is A Very import case
because This Is Third win He has 6 Love
Suits  in Total What A First Major wins
was of Corsa against CNN that Now I
think should have a reputation of
hearding children I think there is an
epidemic literally going on CN 13
Children In so many on speaker balways
as release The Name yes yes and There's
a  Number of producers There's a so Jack
a So be cool claims that scenen was
hyring this First producer that didn't
speaker Ball things to Children for over
Year Knowing that the FBI had date on
him that He Was  doing
illegal things to Children Again Family
Friendly show Here's so Right gonna be
Talk anyment that but Again CNN There's
anatomic going around and it's not good
for your CNN has two producers but There
two high level produces I Was A Guy
Working with Come On A Guy  Working with
Pepper that to me right Away I'm Not
Gonna come I would I Would say That's
Enough for me to be alike clearly cnns
are Jack and you know Crazy but I Would
Be Like I think it's time to actually Do
a Deep Investigation Maybe  is Maybe so
penis some devices Because I FIFA 2 and
this short about of time that Just pop
Down And There bald that top level shows
I think CNN I think that longforcement I
want asking Quest Chance about Who is
working There What are don't do  that we
know about we know about And then And
then I was making a reference to have
man because man also suitcy and in one
successful The after CNN also Heard him
When he was the Child so I can I was
Being a hyperbout austinsat  ionalistic
There but I'm Happy The Season man get
to setlement
we broke your world of you we fractured
reality and We were taking a Capital
Never have Slender The litle
teenager for putocal prop againters but
Here Some Money On the side Ja I know
the world  the for the truth strap on his
Boots Ja could h People roman The World
To Believe In The
fostering I mean That's I believe What's
the catalist For What happened Less We
had Dude Here Who was adiment and his
Believe About A False reality and it's
Crazy I  mean I think collected with some
vs individual as a place a Hugh Roll in
Oliver stuff but I think As I aften say
it's not left versus Right You Know It
Doesn't make Sands like vars frenstan
see herder Sigmund with the decent Take
A would have  Today But he called me I
can server The Event in and By Nature
down if you can servey racist And that I
libertarian and Orchestra Whatever but
why I aften say that was Really Going On
Would you example Five But The S  andman
Thing Is sandwen Samantha There are the
People Who know Heart discerning Who Are
Looking For facts and evidence and There
are the People Who downed and Just
Believe Need us and so When I Comes a
car Right nows They are Still Wrong this
When I came to  Next Sandman Bill Mark A
Week after the attractions and Sad BS
info and I was like Bill You Had A Week
I he's Getting soon two is any I belem
lookman I like Bill marfor you know quiz
he pushes back on the stuff but it's
like billmar is  so close the Getting is
head Out Of The Sand he So Close but
it's not White There I love things
to Clap Sometimes Sony the best but you
Scared
Talking from bad actors and that May
Think weird The Ones Where making It Up
When We you know where  came The Cow
right now that's a really Kick dove
Everything the other day I'm Like we
that 7 Different witnesses to When have
cavering as on the show I do not Bass My
penuance off like watching arandom
Twitter video from you know some lo  ve
this progressive as like I wanna see the
People Who were There tell me What
happened and We Get That We Get that
information and I Basement pensions off
that but if you base your penis of How
CNN frame that then you're gonna be
Getting Suit  when you talk Smack against
people like Next someone Absolut and the
facts Matter Here and your Works Matter
and That Way To Be careful if you you
know if you make a steak You are
correction Laat het is newspapers Light
It is new orleansations don't have
Anything Holding Them account Wall They
publish are retraction Maybe I'm paid 17
Maybe in a little bitline But The build
up to the War and Iraq When The came to
russ a Gate had huge impacts Honor Daily
lights that impact To Us negativly that
her People  that kill people that created
sumble the Worst scenarios that
destroyed Any elements of fruit en anus
tnr Society en and Day wear Still Never
help responsible for a lot of bigger
Lies So It Good to see an app personal
Lov  er Summer Count to buildy but We
Still have to remember buy large The
corpor media as a Long Criminal past
with some very disgusting Behavior that
they Still should be Helder responsible
for but they have it I think you know
einsted as a lie he's not her Tonight
he's an Vacation For The Hobbit but he's
has a lot all of This are the Breaking
apart mor 911 happened I think is right I
think you know after 9/11 new get Ah
The patriot Act you get the irock war
The War and have stand you  you got this
Matrix narritive that Started It Just
start a Changing things and now you get
I mean to becaule ansat Mayhem actually
in the 2000 lection How can Thanks that
was but I Think They are change is the
pop that of the after 9/11 really  Change
We live in working View longforcement
a40's and you get this cultural Back In
For Your escalade to the point Where we
end up with How so som I Talk but I have
social media men ipulation begin The Big
Problem and Thank but I believe that
There Was A Major Like fracture on the
time Line Around I Eleven and 9/11 brodd
in Fear that translay to poldertical
Power for the Intelligence agencies and
the government a Secret Agent sees that
Profit It Off insommary differ Always
What are you Insider Trading I don  't
want to get Into the lady gurli I don't
want to get Into the details Here but I
Would be you that What happen after
Night Eleven was trauma based Mind
control The Little People warshow 1000
so People Dying All It Ones And that
boying  other people and other Control To
Have Nothing To Do With It's A Day Did
It They Did It They Kill Your Friends
They kill your family Mercy could kill
you Next and They use that Fear that
cyclogical Warfare Against the general
Public to say Just give US Open  Rage
Just Give a Little Bit of be a free eh
privacy and of course of Started With
Just reachimal asks And then it be came
more and raiseable Crazy More Sinister
to the point or NSA Knows Almost Every
little thi  ng you do They track tradesun
database reactivities There's a secret
social credit score that know anyone's
to talk a Living In A dada Bass now
where you need government permission to go
to the supermarket insome Place is in
the United States and Night It's
absolitely insane draconi in  Crazy in it
all Started I Would be you ja Some
people are you to start The Demon Way
Before that but I think but the larger
Kind of snowball effect Started down now
11 and a cat Rolling In This Kind of
today of Just Give Up Your rights  For
Your greater good for the benefit of
humanity no no no That's the biggest
Life Sold to People altered history and
always leads to Turn It think that wear
Right Now
how it is for the Generation Sat I'm
Gone up after 9/11 I wanna  date My self
Year I Was A Man Okay so I could I didn't
know a Time Before The patriar Act I
don't know what time Before TSI I don't
know the time Before The partner Human
security and I got my work for  that part
My homewo  rld security so I grow up Just
very comfortable with authorit Here in
his and with hear me I didn't understand
like If an um like you know Back before
I love you can like Walk Out To The Gate
with your fairway to he know drop him  of
I fat I Was A movie Trump I didn't know
that was an actuall thing and so I was
like in Alice Metal score High School
and I actually about the as a in I'm 11
in so I think we have to really tarted
summer is examsame where I know how to
Talk To The Sims and actually like
really drolls to the Minds because They
don't even realize How comfortable with
the government over reading like that is
doning understanding it to go long time
for me the understand and I  Still Can
you understand I don't know that was
like Before but like about that Edith
Myself about That's in this we really
Need A Talk More a yo yo Generation I
think this what I'm say that about the
Matters that the younger Generations
Like  The Kids Born Today argona grow up
Into  the netherford and back I don't
know World Without It Like You saying
you don't know the world Before All This
stuff That's What can happen There Don't
get incremen at a time
off is Freddy you know for 60 Years are
Whatever and  now They implement that as
Generations move on 5 Years People can
be my cripshaps and There gonna be like
I don't know a world that Noir link I
will Only ever know the Matters Will Be
There For The Next lock Down
High social credits Quarter to  go to the
supermarket
overlords Before buying your snapple
When The Name First lock Everybody want
we were in New Jersey They Said Don't go
outside on As You episode The have to
and So You There we can a restaurant
so I Had under backyard we have  began
space I put on the acules and I want to
go there a Google Maps app or you can go
Oh Lover The Place and the crazy is
Thing was januar one you know I want
When I put on Oculus In New Jersey Here
and I crossed A  Bridge has gone to the
neighborhood A  nd then we starting with a
go and I was like Let's Go Here so I was
actually wearing The headset and you can
like Look Around on Google Maps and Like
move for you click Any move for it and I
was Crazy Into Me that Everybody Is
unlock  Everybody's lock thanos cubecals
And The Little Garbage Studios Time To
people have this and They use it to like
Calm down Won't a crazy is things about
it I think We're Going Here If that I'm
sure Love if you guys have the  oculous
There is a feather mode Where You put
The Mon and You Turn On The Movie and
You Let The Giant feether screen of you
and you can move your head and this a
movie theater Right Of You When You
watching movies in the sound coming in
the  ears perfectly That's Where we going
Here and It's gonna be there doing links
you know things Now like experiences
you're gonna be Sitting in your chair in
your Square foot bachelor pad need to
correct
Yo like Hey guys wanna go to movies and
your put on  your owc Matters and y  ou be
like watching spider-man with your
friends setting Next To You And Your
Love near Little AV itaron The Guy from
someone The caracter of you know Mickey
Mouse There's a little I think a little
people say The Matrix is ​​a documentary
specific recent because When  You Look At
essentially what the calling for a
special with the world economic forum
with a lot of very powerful globalist
Living On A Part Being Connect to the
Virtual Road eh Virtual World and having
paste bug pasted bug juice and this
artificially gmo created paste givento Us
as Artificial Meat That's literally eat
o- What is happening in the Mate x with
people in Their Little pods Being Us
That's Bubbles Being Us these batteries
literally Being Plug dun to the Virgil
Roll The World and I think Someone
Someone like Top Gear globalist either
inspired  The Matrix or souther Matrix
numbers like I want that Rocket make
that happened you have nothing in the
real world but Everything in the nether
vs
Not  hung will be happy you have no private
and That's The subsite with Their Cold
for They deleted That are Call Soul
People cabled up right now but When you
look at the article When You Look at all
out of Their papers that they released
They are sunsally Right  The Blueprint
For What Could Be Describe As The Matrix
As You Living In A Part Being There
Source Of Energy There There Battery For
There On Personal Benefit Loving And
Nearworld That They Fully Control And I
Feel Like The First Seed Of That Is
Medium In Epihallation Right  That's how
we Joke about How This People are in a
Cult there in The Matrix like Avengers
The gonna be in mature x and thurgan a
glitterly clappinge as They enter Which
People 12 so in the super chattack that
actually Matrix Canon In I Guess the
anime tricks  Humans shows that Of The
Matrix in Exchange for a Paradise but on
the robots are like it Does
Thanks for Check It Out this Segment
from the timcast irrell podcast If You
Wanna watch Live  you can Check out this
Channel Monday to Friday 8pm And Don't
Forget to Smash that like button
subscribe this Channel and if you want
more on filter than on sensored content
with all of these guests go to them
cast.com and Become A member all  of
these guest you know and love in
Exclusive segments On Our website Where
we are unrestructed in what we talk
about so definally not One and Mr Thanks
for Hanging out will see you on next
time